- All right, well good morning
slash afternoon to everybody.
This is Architecture 313,
maybe your first breakout session so far
that you've attended at re:Invent.
How many people this is
like, other than the keynote,
this is the first thing
you've been able to attend?
A couple people, great.
Well, thank you for making it all the way
to the other side of the conference.
If you attended the keynote this morning
you're the expeditious ones.
Or if you are like staying close
by on this end of the strip
and knew that you wanted to attend this
and you did not attend
the keynote in person,
you're the ones that have
forethought and foresight
to make your time efficient.
So anyway, thank you for being here.
My name is Andrew Baird.
I'm a Senior Principal
Solutions Architect with AWS.
I work out of our Atlanta, Georgia office.
I've been with AWS for
about 13 and a half years,
and there has been no stretch of time
in my entire career in
technology where I have felt
as motivated as,
disrupted, as excited as now for sure.
And my past time at AWS
has been mostly dedicated
to developer-oriented things,
building systems, DevOps, serverless,
our API oriented services, CICD,
and the amount of impact
and the amount of like
capability that's been
delivered to folks like me
and the customers I talked
to in the last 18 months
is mind blowing.
And hopefully everybody in the room
or watching on YouTube,
kind of that resonates with.
And so we're here to talk
to you a little bit about,
for all the folks that maybe
have like career histories
and trajectories like myself
that are software builders,
developers and are like
coming into the fold
of generative AI as it's kind of evolved
into quite a bit of focus around agents.
What are some ways you can take the skills
you've got already and
the things you understand
and bring it into this new world?
So we're gonna have the
agenda broken out as follows.
I'm gonna spend the first
third of the presentation
talking from a perspective of,
from AWS talking about how to think about
and understand agents in the context
of service-oriented architectures.
As a builder, I'm gonna talk about how
some of the design principles and,
important dimensions of building
good distributed systems
that are service-oriented
really lend themselves well
or may have evolved in
the world of agentic AI.
I'll drop a couple ideas
about some services
that have existed even before
today's keynote announcements
that could help you as a builder
getting into generative AI.
And then I'm joined by
Dan DeLauro from WEX
who's gonna go much deeper
into a particular use
case in architecture,
an approach that they
took when building out
their first set of agentic systems
inside of the organization
so that you can hopefully walk away with,
at the end of the session,
with a lot of like deeper understanding
and a new level of comfort
as a software builder
on how you might think about
approaching these topics
and building systems,
building agentic systems,
using a lot of the
knowledge you have already
and getting a lot of like tangible,
credible advice from a team
and a person who's walked that walk
over the last year or so.
So let's jump in.
So agents for builders.
When we've talked about agents
and maybe others have talked about agents,
they're often like displayed
in a way like this.
There's an agent that's doing things
that sound really like personified.
They're observing, they're
taking actions, they're learning.
And when somebody describes
agents to me in this term,
in these kind of terms,
for me as a technologist,
as a practitioner of technology,
it feels fuzzy to me
and it makes me feel like,
does that mean the capabilities
have become so advanced
that there's this software, these models
that are like living inside
of the systems we deploy,
and they have the ability to take actions
and literally learn in a way that makes,
everything that I'm used to
and the way that we build
software feel moot now.
And like technology has
evolved past the point
where all of the skills
that feel comfortable to me
and the knowledge that I've
earned until this point
is being like put at risk in some way.
And so it gives me this premise of like,
does that mean
service-oriented architectures
are dead in some way?
That we now have software elements
that have superseded the context of
how we design distributed systems
and the the way in which
they deliver capabilities?
Is this the message now?
Is this where we've reached?
And so I, as a technologist,
what I like to do in those moments
where you feel like something
is just outside your
grasp of understanding
and you want to dig in a little deeper,
you want to understand it from
like a technical perspective
and you dive a layer deeper
and you get hands on.
So what is like observing and
learning all of those things?
They have like technical meaning in
why those descriptors are
often used for agents,
but really like from a
technical perspective,
talking to builders in the room,
and watching the live YouTube stream.
What is an agent really?
In the center of the story,
there's these LLMs, which I don't need
to describe too much of but
all of the capability that
a model brings to the table
to do things like reason,
to have varying levels of expertise
across different domains and industries.
There's a way in which we want
to like tap that knowledge
and reasoning capabilities
within the context
of some business scenario.
So that's still part of
like, that's a central part
that I'm comfortable
as a software builder,
I'm not a data scientist,
I'm certainly not an AI researcher.
The amount of like,
advanced technology capability
that's embedded inside that model.
I don't understand it
to a deep enough context
to like extract it and describe
it at a builder perspective.
But that's living at
the heart of the systems
that I'm gonna build with agents.
Talking to that LLM, we
have an agent application,
it's usually a container,
a docker container.
There's ways in which
building that software,
and this is maybe what I believe is
one of the biggest advancements
over the last 12 months
is having technology
companies and developers
get a much better understanding at how to,
how to integrate with models in a way
that let them have a
deeper meaningful impact on
different application contexts.
And so the SDKs like Strands
have made it really easy
to build agent applications,
those docker containers
that are gonna be deployed that define
how the software is gonna
interact with the LLM.
So like how the prompts are structured,
how the different turns in
conversation are gonna occur,
how they manage things like
interaction with memory
and past conversations
and integration with tools,
which we'll talk about in a second.
But all of those new elements of how to
well integrate with an LLM
so that you can get
application level capability
out of that model,
is packaged for you in a lot of like neat
and very abstracted ways that developers
are much more comfortable
with and SDKs like Strands.
So I'm gonna call,
I'm gonna draw a box
around those two things.
This docker container-based
deployed application
and the LLM, I'm gonna call that an agent.
And you build those agents
in pretty abstracted ways
using these SDKs that make it easy.
For how like the requests and response
make it into that agent,
we've got a use case,
whether it's an agent
that's sitting inside some
chat bot architecture.
More commonly folks are
recognizing that the ability
to build like autonomous systems
that sit in part of business workflows,
and data architectures,
those inputs and outputs
might be the same types
of messages and events
that you prepackaged
from other upstream applications
and services you have,
but there's some notion
of like a request making it into
the docker container you built
and how that request is
gonna relate to the prompts
that are sent to the LLM
that's sitting at the center.
That agent application and
the SDK used to build it
has some mechanisms
for that agent software
to interact with dependencies.
Maybe the next biggest advancement
that's made building
agent applications easier
is the emergence of MCP just
about 12 months ago this month,
I think when that standard
was first released
and really like, matured to the point
of being adoptable in an
enterprise production landscape
just maybe seven months,
six, seven months ago
as the authentication
story matured a little bit.
So now we have like a docker application,
a bunch of new software capabilities
on how to interact with models,
but then a pretty standardized way
to make requests out to what
our dependencies might be.
And those dependencies can
be software applications,
they can be databases, data resources,
document repositories,
all exposed via like
a standard integration protocol and MCP
that uses service-oriented mechanisms
like folks are used to.
There may be other agents
that it's interacting with
via protocols like A2A.
Those MCP servers that you're writing
may be the integration mechanisms
for integrating with those agents too.
So you've got a couple
different options for
integrating with agents and collectively
you have a story here that feels like
a service-oriented
architecture, hopefully.
We've got docker containers,
we've got integration mechanisms,
we've got the ability
for defining dependencies
and how they interact with each other
and sit in the context of
some business use case.
To me it feels like,
that feels like
service-oriented architecture.
So everybody here should
be encouraged, I believe,
that the way in which agentic applications
are truly being built and developed
has tons of symmetry to the same types
of systems we've been
building for decades.
And so I'll talk in a
minute about different
service-oriented architecture principles
that still largely apply.
There's a lot of net-new
patterns that are emerging
and technologies, it seems like
every week there's new
libraries that are going viral
and new capabilities that are
being announced and launched.
And just know that as
much as it feels like
our heads can spin at
the speed of innovation
that's occurring right now.
Software engineers,
technology builders have been
building muscles at adapting
and remaining flexible in the patterns
that you're embedding into your designs
for years and years and years.
And all of those muscles for
you all and for the builders,
I think sets us up as an
audience to take advantage
of these technologies
rather than necessarily
just be disrupted by them.
It sets us up nicely.
So take confidence in that premise.
And then lastly, don't forget
non-functional requirements.
We've seen somebody that talks to
hundreds of customers throughout the year
and what they want to do with agents
and how they've been building so far,
the amount of like technical magic
that feels like is occurring
as folks build these systems,
lends itself to being,
it's very easy to forget the things like
operational excellence and
security and resilience
are things that don't come for free
that they need to be intentionally built
into the designs that you have,
and there are a lot of folks
that I think would attend
a session like this
have probably been that
voice in the room in the past
while building systems that
know things like scalability
are important to include
into the design upfront
in the design thinking.
So all of that, all of
those tendencies you have
as a builder are gonna lend themselves
to making you really valuable
as agent applications are
being built and developed.
Okay, so let's talk about
some design principles.
So on these next set of
slides, there's gonna be
kind of an evolution of some
principles and terminology
that hopefully folks are
largely familiar with
and how they would apply
in like an API-based distributed system
and the design principles that apply.
And then we're gonna
talk about some new ones
that we'll try and explain
in a set of like terminology
that maybe will like, feel more familiar
like in the lexicon of
building distributed systems,
but are new things you need to consider
inside of building agentic systems.
So here's a set of
equivalent design principles
I'm gonna say,
when you're building agentic systems
versus all the distributed systems
you've built historically.
So loose coupling still totally applies.
How you deploy those docker containers,
how you think about like the,
the benefits of things like
asynchronous processing
of like having no shared
concerns between systems,
being able to scale various aspects
of a distributed system independently.
The way in which an
agentic use case is gonna
sit inside the architecture.
All of those principles still apply
in very, very much the same way.
For modularity, I think this is one
where we've seen a tendency
to build anti-patterns in
the space inside of agents
compared to service-oriented architecture.
So rather than having
agents that are expected
to handle a lot of various different tasks
and context within the same use case,
all be built as part of the same set
of prompts, systems instructions
that you're gonna deliver
to a particular use case.
The ability to think of agent granularity
much in the same way as you
think about service granularity
as you're building microservices
and service-oriented architectures,
the same types of trade-offs exist.
So if you have a use case
where it's like very logical
how you might break down
those tasks along different
business logic lines or ownership lines
or security segmentation,
the same types of
benefits you'd have gotten
when building services in that way,
you'll get from building
multi-agent systems
in that same way.
On the flip side of having modular agents,
making the tools that you build reusable.
So reusability and having the ability for
a rest service satisfy the requirements
of many different clients
that are integrating with it.
You want to build your
components of tooling,
your MCP servers with that
same kind of mindset in mind
where if you have like a retail context,
and you've got an MCP server
that's talking to your,
your order history systems
and exposing information
about past transactions and
orders that have been placed.
If you have various
different agents within
a customer support context and
the E-commerce buying context
and the fulfillment context all
having their own MCP servers
that talk to the same set
of eventual backend sources of truth,
you're gonna find yourself
in the same types of
lack of consistency and problems
that would've emerged
in a service-oriented landscape before.
So having your tools and MCP servers
be built in a reusable way,
and being built by like the appropriate
business line domains that
own those topics today.
We've seen like more of a pattern emerge
where the agents that are being built
are often very use-case oriented
and sit close to the
edge of an organization,
and they're building
MCP tools for themselves
that their own agents need and
they're building the proxies
between their own agents
and the backend architectures
that they need to integrate with.
And we find it's much more efficient
and scalable over the long term to instead
think of the MCP server
as like an extension
of the service integration mechanism
for those sources of truth
that different agents
are gonna integrate with.
Okay, discoverability.
Just like you'd have
service registries and
copious documentation about
what the different capabilities are
of a particular distributed
system and service or API,
you want agents to have the
same type of capability.
It should be obvious to anybody
who's meant to interact with an agent
or part of a technology team
that is meant to integrate
with an agentic system that you've built
or a developer that's being
onboarded into your organization
to have a very clear understanding
of what the intended boundaries are
for an agent that you've built, right?
And the good news is a lot
of these things are a
little more self-evident
when building agents to humans
than building APIs in the past.
There's a lot of stuff
we do in natural language
when building agents that
make it a little easier
to be discoverable.
But the same general concept applies
that as you're building agents,
the need to maintain like
team-wide, department-wide,
company-wide catalogs of
where those agents are
and like what their
capabilities are meant to do,
how to integrate with them,
documentation for them,
where the observability
points are for them.
All of those things apply
to agent systems just like you would have
when you're building
service-oriented architectures.
So now let's talk about
a couple principles,
a few principles that I'm gonna say
have evolved a little bit.
Still like,
like at their core there's
there's ways in which
the knowledge you have
about a prior principle
in service-oriented design
is gonna like transition
naturally into the new world.
But there's a little nuance or
a way that some contradiction
might have emerged that you
need to take into account.
So the benefits of statelessness
in service-oriented design
have been well understood
for a really long time.
The benefits that gives you to resilience
and scalability like deployment safety,
having as much statelessness
embedded in an architecture as possible
was always a practical
thing to strive for.
But now we know in agent applications
having persistent contextual memory
across multi-turn
conversations potentially,
or use cases within workflows
that require multiple turns,
having contextual memory be embedded
as part of the context window
for the agent that's performing the tasks
or achieving the goals that you define.
This is an important part of
getting the most capability
as you can out of an agent.
So there's elements of
the data architecture,
the memory in particular
that is gonna feel,
it might feel a little unnatural
as like a distributed systems
builder coming from the past
to be comfortable with the idea that
the runtime application of an agent
is gonna have a lot of, like,
you can think of it as session state,
but conversation state and memory
be building within the same use case,
the same runtime
infrastructure that's deployed.
And that adds a couple
different dimensions
that you need to be conscious of.
It means that
as memory gets embedded
in these multi-term conversations,
that things like scalability
and deployment safety
across like when users
are in the middle of having a conversation
or work is in the midst of being done,
what that means for your use case,
the idea if you were gonna
disrupt a multi-term conversation
in the midst of it happening
and what the user experience
is meant to look like,
while that's happening in real time.
Next, let's talk about
orchestration versus
autonomous coordination.
So still, like the idea
of building logical graphs
and the types of work that should occur
and understanding what the dependency flow
and structure looks like for
the architecture you build,
those things were very deterministic
and able to be documented
and understand at design time
in the world of distributed systems
and using capabilities like step functions
from us and other like
graph-based workflow platforms.
But with agents you have the ability
to let the coordination emerge at runtime
as the type of non-deterministic work
that you might want to take advantage of,
it's possible for there
to be multiple use cases
that a single agent
system is gonna satisfy.
And depending on the type
of request that comes in
and the context for it,
you may have different
specialized agents downstream
that handle different components of it.
So understanding like how coordination
is meant to relate to each other
and how that coordination is described
and how to allow it to emerge at runtime
versus just defining it
in a very discreet way.
And you have trade-offs here you can make,
and Dan's portion of the conversation,
there may be use cases where
you want more determinism
in the workflow that you're building
and you don't want a lot of
like emerged coordination
that's more autonomous
and non-deterministic at a macro level.
And you can combine some
of the principles here
with the principles you know,
and the patterns you have
from service-oriented architecture,
like patterns of the past
that will still apply.
So next service contracts
and capability emergence,
like has been fundamentally important
and like good API design
to understand like the concepts
of backward compatibility
and like client-server
relationship at the contract level,
and what the different data elements were
and like the allowed values
and like ranges of those
values was a key part
of what allowed
service-oriented architectures
to proliferate and be stable.
But in the world of agents,
capability can emerge at runtime.
And it's a benefit of it.
The idea that as like tools change
and capabilities are deployed,
you don't have to update
layers of your agentic stack
in order to expose those things
and expect the agent to
like evolve its behavior
through coding changes you've made.
As those tools, descriptions
and capabilities
emerge over time, the agent
will discover them at runtime
and it will allow new capability to emerge
as tools are built and as they change
and as capabilities are released,
those things can emerge,
can emerge in real time.
I'm gonna call it totally
new design principles
that folks need to get comfortable with.
Software engineers often joke
that a lot of what our
career has boiled down to
has been building crud,
you know, building, create,
read, update, delete,
and a million different business contexts.
But in the end, if you're
talking about business logic,
there's some way in which
the code you're working on
on any given day is gonna boil down
to building some form of crud
related to some type of
business domain object
or technical domain object.
And that meant that helps
ground your design thinking
and the patterns that you're gonna build,
and things are very different now.
And the way in which you think about
like how to prioritize what
use cases are a good fit
and what models are gonna be
like practically applied to,
you need to pivot your design thinking
to this idea of goals, that goals are
like the new unit of
technical work being done
rather than crud.
And if you can distill the type of
value you want your
software system to deliver
to your business or your customers
in the context of a very
succinctly describable goal,
there's a good chance that
a model will understand
the work that you're trying to achieve,
and you'll get a better idea of like
what data and what context
needs to be delivered
into that model to achieve the goal.
Reasoning transparency.
So the whole idea of reasoning
as like a deployable piece of technology
is fundamentally new on its own,
but it means that observability
is fundamentally different too.
The logs that we used to gather
needed to only include a lot of metadata
about the actions that were taken,
metadata about those actions,
the events that occurred
within the sequence of code,
so timestamps and like where
elements of code were executed,
and now there's this
non-deterministic ability for software
to think inside of your architecture
and being able to think
about how you want to ingest
that observability into an architecture
and use it thoughtfully when
you have operational reasons
to review it or analyze it or debug it.
So having a good set of ideas
of how reasoning transparency
and the evidence of it
is part of your operational pipelines,
and architectures is a key new thing
that you need to think about,
building other distributed systems
to ingest in the process
and things like that.
Self-correction.
There's tons of patterns
like circuit breaker
and others where error handling
and fault handling has been
a large portion of what
can make distributed systems reliable.
Agents have like a general
tendency to want to self-correct
and find ways to achieve
their goal via multiple paths.
And there may be times where
this is a big benefit for you
and there's other times where you may not
want an agent to take advantage of this.
So having a very explicit understanding
that at build time at like the definition
of the agentic system you're
designing and deploying,
that this tendency exists
inside of the agent you're building
and what it might mean, the
different error scenarios are
that we'll encounter,
whether it be like a tool is unavailable
or like access changes occur
that limit its capability
and how an agent may react to those things
and what would you want its behavior to be
in those scenarios?
And to take those things into account
as you're building your instructions,
designing your downstream
dependency architectures
and all of those things is net-new work
that you should be thinking about
as a service-oriented builder.
And then lastly, like
maybe most fundamentally
is this idea of
non-determinism in general,
understanding that the type of testing
that you're able to do,
we just announced this
morning AgentCore evaluations,
which can play a huge role here.
There's ways in which
that fundamental premise
that the software work being done
is gonna be non-deterministic,
is gonna change
a lot of the typical ways
in which you've achieved some
operationally-related goals
for agentic systems compared
to how you worked before.
Okay, now I'm gonna just
gonna run through things
that hopefully if you're in the session,
you understand these services
are available already,
but I've mentioned Strands a little bit
a couple times already,
but AWS's mindset here
is like adopt an agent
framework in general.
Don't feel like you need to write software
that's gonna integrate with
all your models out of the box
in some sophisticated way
without taking advantage
of the SDKs on the market,
and Strands, we think it was
released at a very neat time
where the model capabilities
and their ability to reason
really advanced to the point
where it let us build an SDK that hit
a really nice sweet spot
on making the ability
to develop quickly and
reach production quickly
at the like the appropriate
level of traction
that leans into the model's capabilities
to reason without a lot of
like design time complexity,
but still a ton of robust operational
and security benefits that
you get from using it too,
so choosing the right agent SDK.
For like building and
authoring the code related
to everything I've described so far,
We have the KIRO CLI and the KIRO IDE.
You have the ability to adopt cloud code,
you can have your model
inference for the cloud models
behind cloud code get deployed on Bedrock.
If you're a team that
manages like model governance
and access inside your enterprise
and you like the Bedrock model of that,
you can have cloud code be
backed by a Bedrock model.
And so many of the things like as you
as software engineers are
learning these things,
there's new capabilities that are gonna
help you author the software
and produce it for you without you
having to get down to that
level of detail yourself.
And then obviously
Bedrock AgentCore Runtime
as you more and more are
gonna be responsible for
understanding like the
high level translation
between business requirements into
the prompting and
co-development you're gonna do
with agentic systems,
having an infrastructure
platform like AgentCore Runtime
that extracts as much as it can
on the infrastructure
side in a serverless way,
and give you a lot of confidence
that like the AWS reputation from
operational excellence and security
are gonna be embedded in that story
is gonna like help you accelerate
and get to production more quickly.
And then I just want to call out here
that the AgentCore Runtime
where the docker containers
get deployed can also be
your MCP servers that you build as well.
So all the different
tools that you might build
for your agents deploying
to AgentCore Runtime
is a place those MCP servers
can be deployed as well.
Okay, so that's all the
general kind of overview
that I'm gonna provide you today.
I'm gonna pivot over
to Dan and Dan from WEX
is gonna come up and talk to
you about their experience
building agents as a company.
- Thank you.
Am I on? All right.
Good afternoon everybody.
My name's Dan DeLauro,
I'm a Solutions Architect
on the cloud engineering team at WEX.
And let me change my slide here.
There we go.
It's the right button, sorry about that.
So last year I was
sitting out there, right,
and I was in a session just like this
and I was hearing about
Bedrock and agentic
and all these new tools that
make it look really easy
to build with AI,
but it always kind of felt a
little bit out of reach, right?
Like Andrew, I'm no data scientist,
I don't have a background
in machine learning
and I'm not building neural networks,
but I didn't need any of that
because honestly, as
builders, all of us, right?
As people who understand
systems and patterns
and architecture, we've
actually got an advantage.
And that's kind of what
prepared me for all that.
Like the building part though,
like this speaking thing is new,
that's a new thing for me, but I'm here.
So thanks for coming out.
Today, I'd like to talk about how
we've been using Bedrock agents
and now AgentCore to enrich
our operational support at WEX.
And I think you'll see
a lot of the principles
and a lot of the things that
Andrew covered, they're there,
and they're kind of what
made that possible for us.
And they're really what
helped us go from pilot
to production in under three months.
And now we've got well
over 2000 users internally,
so it's been a good year.
But first we've got the company slide.
In case you don't know who we are,
WEX is a global commerce platform.
We power mobility, benefits,
and payment solutions
for organizations in
more than 200 countries.
We operate one of the world's largest
proprietary fleet networks,
and we help consumers manage
their benefits accounts,
things like HSAs and
FSAs and LSAs and COBRA.
And we handle everything
from corporate travel
to expense management, all with the goal
of simplifying the business
of running a business.
Last year we processed over
$230 billion in transactions
in more than 20 different currencies.
So it kind of goes without saying, right?
Our platforms need to be
reliable, they need to be secure,
and they have to run at scale.
And that's where Global
Technology Services comes in.
Now we're sort of the
team behind the teams.
We designed the shared services that drive
platform engineering standards,
reliability, governance,
cost optimization, all the paved roads
that let everybody move really fast
without getting into trouble.
My team's job at WEX, sorry,
is to make cloud feel
simple even when it isn't.
And last year Global Technology
saw more than 40,000 support requests.
Now that's a lot, right?
But if you think about it,
every last one of them
is critical to somebody,
even if they are repetitive
and time consuming for us.
And we've got operations and we've got SRE
and support at all of those tiers,
but we're always looking for
ways to reduce that number
without reducing quality.
So like everyone else,
we started looking at AI,
but we didn't want to do
anything flashy or complicated.
We just wanted to start small
and build something simple
that would just quietly
make our lives easier.
And that's what inspired
us to build ChatGTS.
And in case you don't
see what we did there,
GTS is just short for
Global Technology Services.
It's kind of got a ring to it, right?
But anyways, I promise
there's more to this than a chatbot story.
Sure it can chat, it lives in our chat,
it can read our documentation
and it'll do Q and A all day.
But underneath it's evolving
into more of a virtual engineer,
one that understands cloud and network
and security and operations.
But we're not replacing people,
we're just doing what we do in operations.
We're automating the repetitive stuff
and we're expanding our
self-service capabilities.
Really, we're just
trying to free people up
so they can focus on the
problems that matter,
the ones that actually
move the business forward.
But we had to start somewhere, right?
We didn't want to just build
agents because we could,
or get stuck in that cycle
of chasing shiny objects
whenever something new came out.
So we looked at our data,
our support history,
and those 40,000 tickets,
and then we asked ourselves
what are we seeing the most, right?
Which are the most complex
or just flat out painful?
Really, where are we
spending the most time?
And then we looked at the places
where we had existing
automation or runbooks
or some kind of a process
that people were already executing,
and we realized that was the sweet spot,
that high volume, high
friction, well understood work,
that's where we knew we
could make a dent with AI.
And I brought two examples to share today,
but keep in mind we did start with chat
and we focused on Q and A
so that we could build
up our knowledge base.
And we saw immediately,
now instead of opening a ticket
just to find information,
people were able to come
and find it on their own.
And we were building
agents that could leverage
that knowledge base to
make their own decisions.
So that was sort of like
setting the foundation
and laying the platform for all of this.
But now,
this first example is honestly
my least favorite ticket,
and hopefully some of
you will understand why
when we get to it.
But the second one is
a little more exciting
because we're moving beyond chat,
and we're embracing event-driven
design with AgentCore.
But together, I think they show
how AI can really become
a part of operations,
not a side project,
but more like a teammate
who's always on call.
So can anybody relate to this?
Has anyone ever had a network issue
they've had a troubleshoot?
Well, I know you do, right?
Well, consider yourself lucky,
because at WEX we operate
hundreds of AWS accounts,
and we've got Azure and Google
all spanning eight regions
and multiple on-prem data centers,
and it's all interconnected.
Now you probably know
there's a lot of tech
that goes into making that possible.
So when something inevitably
fails, it can be challenging.
Even with the right tools, it's hard.
So picture this, it's almost noon,
you're getting ready to go to lunch
and you get a ping in your support chat,
and it's Jared from the
PAS engineering team,
and he's like, dude, we're blocked.
We're trying to deploy this cluster
and we're in this new VPC
and we're expecting it to
reach all these things.
Now, Jared doesn't have access
to the transit gateways,
or the firewalls or the VPNs,
and even if he did,
maybe it's a little out of his wheelhouse,
but that's not his job, right?
You know that feeling.
You like Jared,
you don't want leave him hanging,
but you want to go to lunch.
Now you almost,
it's like you don't have a
choice, you have to respond.
Well now you don't
because we built an agent
that can respond for you.
And now what used to require
all this tribal knowledge
across all these different domains,
it can happen in minutes
and anyone can use it now, even Jared.
Now in this example,
it's an EKS cluster and the
agent knows it's an AWS,
and it could go into
our core network account
and it can use reachability analyzer.
So it provisions a network analysis path,
and we know that takes a while.
So while that's running,
it fans out and it checks flow logs,
it looks at any recent
changes in the network,
and then it looks to see if
there's any known issues, right?
There could be something
already happening.
But by the time it's done,
it's collected all of this information
from all of the things it's looked into,
and it breaks it down in natural language
and presents it to you,
the end user, in chat.
And it shows you exactly where
that traffic dropped and why.
So now when Jared needs to escalate,
he can do it with the right team
and all of the right information.
And since we're logging all
of these investigations,
we're able to spot recurring issues
and maybe we identify opportunities
for some tighter
guardrails in the network.
But at the end of the day,
this is a perfect example
of how an agentic system can
scale maybe where humans can't.
Now, the second one is my current favorite
because you know, like I said,
this was more than a chat bot.
Now we're building agents
that are responding to alerts
and anomalies, and they're understanding
the state of a system before
they're deciding how to react.
They're not just hanging
out waiting for a ping.
And honestly, this is the best kind of AI
because you don't even
realize you're using it.
And we all love EKS, right?
Containers, they're gonna
solve all our problems
and you know it's gonna save the world,
but they're not always the answer.
Now, don't judge, but at WEX,
we've still got some critical workloads
that just make more sense running on EC2,
but we still have to support them.
So picture this, you've got
an EBS spike out of nowhere,
your CloudWatch lights up
and you can almost smell the smoke right?
Now, this could be a warning shot,
but why chance it if we
can get in front of it?
But if that workload matters,
someone's getting a page,
somebody's gotta wake
up, they gotta log in,
then they gotta figure
out what's happening,
where is it happening?
They're checking logs, maybe
they're running Playbooks
to expand the volume, or
maybe they're just topping on
and clearing some space.
Whatever they're doing, that takes time.
And let's be honest, nobody
wants to do that at 2:00 a.m.
I certainly don't.
And that's one of the
reasons we built this,
but it's the reality today.
So now we can flip the
script a little bit.
Take a sip of this real quick.
All right, so instead
of paging an engineer,
we can send these alerts to an agent
with all of those metrics and context.
So now we're not calling anybody,
we're not waking anyone up.
That's no longer that
first line of defense.
The agent can see what's
happening, where it's happening,
and it can find an agent
or a team of agents to
help with the issue.
Now, our first agent does some discovery.
This is like triage.
It looks at the operating
system, it looks at the version,
it looks to see which
platform it belongs to.
It looks to see how critical it is.
And then it looks at history.
It looks to see has this happened before?
How many times have we
expanded the volume here?
You know, we maintain policies
to cap expansion, right?
You don't want to just keep adding disc,
you're kicking the can down the road,
and that's never gonna work.
So at this point, if anything looks off
the agent steps out of the way
and we escalate back to a human
and then we're back to
the way we do it now.
But if not, our agent
can connect into Jira
through AgentCore Gateway
and it can open a ticket
and start logging the incident.
Now think about it, this analysis is huge
because you're collecting
all of the inputs you're
gonna need a week later
if it evolves to an incident
and you need to craft an RCA document.
So now that we know what's happening,
it passes on to a maintenance agent,
and this agent can choose
from a library of
preexisting SSM documents.
Now, keep in mind, these
are the same documents
that our ops engineers
are using at 2:00 a.m.
We've got Playbooks to
run diagnostics and backup
and cleanup and expansion.
It's all the usual runbooks,
but we've exposed them as tools
to the agent on an MCP server.
So now whatever the agent decides to do,
it's using the same automations
that we already trust,
and we're not waking somebody
up to push that run button.
We've eliminated the chats,
the texts, the pages,
the cross team escalations,
and now these systems,
they're starting to learn
how to take care of each other.
And as they learn,
they're building memory.
And over time they can
start to recognize patterns.
Now we can learn where we're starting to,
we're cleaning up on occasion
where we have to escalate
and maybe they start to spot issues
at the application layer.
Now, that's what makes this
feel less like automation,
and more like a team.
This gets smarter over time.
And once the issue is resolved,
we can update Jira
through AgentCore Gateway,
and then we can publish status
to SNS through an MCP server.
And from here we can notify
engineers, on-call systems,
dashboards, whatever else
is downstream from there.
But we're not done yet.
This same agent is gonna
follow that resource
all the way upstream back to the Terraform
or the cloud formation
or whoever or whatever
built in in the first place.
And it's gonna open a pull request,
or it's gonna create a Jira
issue, or send an email.
It's gonna do something
that closes that loop
between operations and infrastructure,
so we can remediate that drift
we introduced in the incident.
Now, I'm gonna be honest, I've
been doing this a long time
and I've seen some cool stuff,
but when I see stuff
like this work for real,
the first couple of times
I still kind of feel like a little kid.
It feels like magic, right?
And I just hope it sparks some ideas
and inspires, to see what's possible
when you think about
applying AI to operations,
I know this is a basic example,
we're just expanding a volume here,
but we're just getting started.
This is us learning how to
use what we already know,
and we're reusing what already works.
It's not magic, it's just
engineering and architecture.
And that's kind of the point.
So I'm gonna zoom out,
I'm gonna talk a little
bit about how we got there,
and then we can look at some diagrams,
we'll see what it looks
like under the hood.
So when we started this, we knew we wanted
to build more than a chat bot
and a rag pipeline, right?
We wanted to create a platform.
We wanted something sustainable,
something extensible,
something that would inspire
all of the other teams to come
and collaborate and help us expand this,
because operations takes a village.
But we didn't have to change
the way we built things.
We just had to let these old
patterns breathe a little bit.
And it was all the same stuff.
You know, we built agents with boundaries,
we gave them clear responsibilities,
and we let them all work independently.
And we saw guardrails become the contracts
for what those agents
could and couldn't do.
And events, it became less
about, something happened,
and more about, here's what
happened, here's what it means,
here's what we can do,
and here's what we did
the last time it happened.
And of course, observability, right?
We still need to see everything,
but there's more to this
than 200s and 500s now.
We're looking at behavior and reasoning.
There's nothing new though.
It all translates and it
all still makes sense.
So here's what it looks like.
Out of the gate, I'll be honest,
it was a little challenging
because at WEX we don't use
Slack, we don't use Teams,
we use Google Chat, and there
is no native integration
between Google and AWS for collaboration.
So on the left, left right,
we have our users chatting with
us in our workspace domain.
Now those requests come over the internet.
So in the middle we have
our WAF, with Imperva,
that secures our inbound traffic.
And on the right we
have our AWS environment
fronted by API gateway.
And from there we use a Lambda
to route and acknowledge messages.
And then we use Step Functions
to orchestrate all of our agents.
We store state and
conversations in Dynamo,
reasoning traces land in S3.
And of course Bedrock hosts
our agents and knowledge.
On paper it looks pretty simple.
It's neat, it's easy, it's serverless,
it's exactly what we wanted.
Now our chat application is
only assigned to the users
who are allowed to use it.
And all of those messages
come with a signed token
that we can validate, and
then it hits our router.
And here we can filter out
noise, oversized prompts,
and we can send a quick
response to that user,
basically saying, hey, we
got it, we're working on it.
And that helps sort of
absorb the model latency
because agents still take
a while to do their work.
But really at the front, at the edge,
this is just a clean,
well-defined contract
for everything else downstream,
and it keeps our front door predictable.
Now, I'll admit before this,
I never really did much
with Step Functions.
I know they're on all the exams
and everybody has to learn 'em,
but I always felt like
they were just for people
who built too many Lambdas.
But, it turns out they're
actually perfect for AI.
You know, Bedrock gave
us the intelligence,
the parts that can think and
create and make decisions.
Step Functions gave us
the discipline we needed
to keep it all in check.
We used the retries and
fallbacks and state transitions,
and that's where it really clicked.
You know, like Andrew said, these agents,
they can be autonomous,
but they don't have to be.
You can give them as much freedom
or as much control as you need to,
and that's what made them fit
so well in these operational workflows.
So Google gives us a trusted identity,
but it has no concept of permissions.
That token really only tells us
that you're allowed to talk to us.
So we take that identity
and we reach out to active directory
and we fetch your entitlements
and cash them in Dynamo.
Kept it pretty simple.
It's all based on group
memberships and OU.
And that way we're not
beating up on systems
that were never really
meant for real time traffic.
So basically Google tells us who you are.
This is how we figure out
what you're allowed to do
and how far you can go before
you ever reach an agent.
And when we invoke that agent,
we wrap the entire prompt in context tags,
and we include your identity
and your entitlements
and send that downstream to the agent.
So now whatever the user claims,
the agent only trusts that
context because it's immutable.
And here, if something goes
sideways, say the agent fails
or times out or can't produce a response,
we log the error and we can
send a safe response back
to the user without blowing
up the whole workflow.
Now, once the agent responds,
we want to capture everything.
We store messages in Dynamo
and trace traces in S3,
and from there we format the response,
so it looks good in chat.
You know, Google has their
own markdown language,
and that allows us to include
citations and reference links
and any attachments that came back.
And then we update that temporary message
we send from the router.
And that really, that takes what feels
like a request response
and it turns it into
more of a transaction.
It's more like an actual conversation.
And that's kind of the point.
So really that's how
Step Functions helped us.
It gave us this structure
where there was so much
potential for chaos.
And it's all the same patterns, right?
There's retries and fallbacks
and circuit breakers,
and it's baked into
every state transition.
That helped us hold all of these
creative parts accountable.
And now we can observe it,
and we can measure it just
like any other workflow.
So when it came to agents,
I mean we were inspired by SOA, right?
Think about what it taught us
to break up the monolith, right?
We took these big systems
and we turned them into smaller
pieces with a clear purpose.
That same discipline applies to agents,
and we built specialized agents
and gave them one job that
they have to do really well.
And that keeps the focus really clean
and the reasoning sharp,
and then the handoffs between
agents is even cleaner.
But instead of having
one giant orchestrator
pulling all the strings, ours
acts more like a conductor,
it sits in the middle,
it can interpret intent,
and then it could figure
out what's happening,
where is it happening,
and then it connects that
problem to the right expert
or the right team of experts.
But even experts need boundaries.
With all this autonomy, we
needed to have guardrails.
We needed some way
that we could enforce
policy and compliance,
so we applied guardrails at
the edge with the orchestrator,
and this gives us defense
in depth for every decision
that happens in the platform.
Now, we're sanitizing
text, we're blocking topics
and redacting PII, both on
the way in and on the way out.
So now the guardrails, they're
not just protecting our data,
they're actually protecting
the agents from themselves
so they can wander, right?
But they still can't color
outside of the lines.
But none of this works
unless they're all operating
on this same source of truth.
And that's where shared
knowledge comes in.
Now, all of our agents tap
into the same knowledge base.
So that means when we have a Q and A agent
answering a question about connectivity,
it's pulling from the same
material an ops agent would
if it were troubleshooting.
They're separate services,
but it's consistent understanding.
It's like giving every
application in your service layer,
this unified data plane,
only now it's made up of runbooks
and reference architectures
and living documentation.
But thinking isn't enough, right?
At some point, we gotta let
the agents do something,
but they act just like any
other service on the network.
They're calling APIs and CP servers.
They're executing the
tools we've given them
to do their jobs.
So with Bedrock action groups,
we can run these Lambdas
inside of our VPCs with
tightly scoped permissions,
and then we can control
what they can reach
and what they can't reach.
And at the end of the day,
it's just services talking to services
just like any other application
layer on the network.
So how do we define that truth?
Documentation, of course.
And ironically, that was the
hardest part of all this,
because at the enterprise,
you know it can live anywhere.
And even when people can find it,
they don't like to read it,
but they'll chat with it, that's for sure.
So we wanted to build something
that could grow and evolve
with the organization,
and we needed something more
than just a a dumping ground
for files in S3.
So we chose Kendra, with the Gen AI index
because it gives us this hybrid.
We get keyword and vector search
with multimodal embeddings,
and with all of the built-in connectors
for things like Confluence
and GitHub and Google Drive,
we're able to keep all of our information
in sync automatically
with Chron schedules.
Now it includes source code and diagrams
and policies and runbooks.
It's like all of our domain expertise
finally lives in this
one searchable layer.
And the best part about that
is it actually comes to us.
We don't have to chase it down anymore.
We don't have to find the documentation.
The real breakthrough wasn't
just building a knowledge base,
it was figuring out how are
we gonna manage this thing?
It's those data sources
for Terraform, for Kendra,
they're configured in Terraform
and they live in GitHub, and
we deploy them with CICD.
So with self-service, we allow the people
who own that content, the
subject matter experts,
to maintain it themselves.
They can open a pull request
and we can deploy their changes
through GitHub's pipelines.
Now, it's still enterprise knowledge,
we're just treating it
like infrastructure now.
I'm not gonna lie,
observability was a bit of a puzzle.
Like we have this third party
chat up on the front end,
this hybrid identity between
Google and Active Directory.
And we had Lambdas and
Step Functions and Bedrock.
It started to feel like we
had metrics coming at us
from every direction.
So we had to find a way
to stitch it all together
so we could actually
see what was happening.
So we built this
persistence layer in Dynamo,
and this is where we store the things
we care about long term.
This is all of our users, their
chat spaces, their sessions,
all of their messages.
But it's not a transcript.
This is relationships.
Because every item here keys back
to a session and a trace ID.
And those traces land in S3,
and this became our black box.
This is like the flight recorder
that captures every decision
that's made across the platform.
I mean, it's basically
distributed tracing, right?
But instead of following a request,
we're following a train of thought.
And of course we needed transparency.
So we pushed all of our logs
into Splunk through Kinesis,
and now even info security and compliance
and risk and legal,
they've all got a real time view
of what's happening in the platform.
They can see what people are saying,
they can see what the agents are saying.
They can see all of the redactions,
all of the policies being enforced.
And at the end of the
day, everyone's happy.
Now, I'm gonna say this
like it was 10 years ago,
because it feels like it,
but it was only four or five weeks.
But back when we started,
there was no AgentCore.
There was no built-in observability,
but we still needed a way to
understand what was happening.
So we got together and
we built this dashboard
that produces some practical insights.
And of course when I say
we, I mean me and my team
and Cursor and Claude and Copilot,
but all my smartest friends helped out.
But literally with this dashboard,
we can replay a conversation step by step,
and then we can see the
story sort of unfold.
We can see what people are asking for.
We can see where the
agents are struggling,
and we can see where maybe
our knowledge base needs some work.
But this kind of visibility
doesn't just measure
quality, it shapes it.
This is what drives our roadmap.
This is what tells us what
we need to build next.
I'm almost done, I promise.
It's my last one, then everybody can go.
This was a big year for AI.
All the new models, all the
new services, the tools,
all the new acronyms that we're secretly
Googling on the side,
and I hope I'm not the only
one who has to do that.
But honestly, I've never
had more fun learning
and building at the same time.
And I feel really lucky that I get to work
with this stuff because it's awesome.
It just is.
I learned a lot this year,
but there's three lessons I'm
gonna carry into next year
that I want to share with you.
Number one, the architecture
still matters, right?
It's all the same diagrams.
There's new services
and there's new icons,
but you don't need to be a data scientist
to piece it all together.
I feel like I'm living proof of that.
And second, you don't
have to build a platform.
You can start small, but think big.
Build something simple that will teach you
what to build next.
And of course, please breathe right?
Go outside, touch some grass.
Maybe wait till you get home.
There's not a lot of grass in Vegas,
but seriously, it's way too easy
to get wrapped up in all this tech, right?
We still have a say in this,
don't let it overtake you
because you could blink,
and the next thing you know,
you're in Vegas on the stage
and you're explaining
what you did last year,
'cause that could happen, trust me.
Thank you.
This was awesome.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Dan. Thank you everybody.
Hope you enjoy the rest of the conference.
Remember, if this is your first one,
we've got surveys that come out.
Really helps us and gives us the ability
to speak in the future,
especially if you enjoy the session here.
So have fun this week.
Stay safe, enjoy the party on Thursday,
and thanks again.